What's your background, Hank?
Hello, I'm
originally Baptist, but I'm currently
going through OCIA currently.
And uh
I had a
So, basically I'm I'm reading, you know,
the the catechism and going through
everything and um
I'm about 99% on board with everything.
All right.
>> Um the the one thing that keeps giving
me trouble is how um
the church handles abuses. Like they
they shuffle priests around and they
like don't not to say that they don't,
you know, prosecute certain priests that
have been, you know, abusing
>> mean. I know. I know.
It's troubling how they covered up.
So, I guess my question is because you
in in your journey you you came from
Protestantism to Catholicism. Yes. How
um how you reconciled that because I
have a I have a little daughter and if
uh something happened to her at the
hands of a priest, I don't know if I
could contain myself. No, I I know.
100% on the money.
The [snorts] reason why
in spite of all the corruptions and the
abuses and uh clergy
praying on young boys, which is rampant.
That no one's going to deny that.
Why that did not deter me is because of
my knowledge of scripture. So, I
appreciate your question and I've done
many sections on this.
It's because I've read the Old Testament
and I've seen how corrupt the kings of
Israel and Judah were.
Let's just go with David himself. David
committed adultery
and a man to cover his sin. And yet God
never defrocked He remained a king
and a prophet who wrote inspired
scripture.
His successor, Solomon,
married 700 women, 300 concubines who
are foreign women, and he started
sacrificing to their gods and goddesses.
And yet God did not defrock him, nor did
he remove him from the throne.
Though he divided the kingdom,
separating into two, he still kept part
of the kingdom
within the line of David. Then you look
at the kings of Israel, all of them were
corrupt, steeped in idolatry,
immorality, and fan aside. Same with
many of the kings of Judah. So, if God
ordained the Davidic kingdom, the
kingdom on Israel, and yet most of the
people that assumed those offices were
corrupt, immoral, murderous, idolatrous.
Without this implying that this is not
of God,
then I can't, if I'm to be consistent
with scripture, say cuz we got scum,
homosexual clergy who pray on youth, or
who even sleep with one another cuz
they're wolves in sheep's clothing, that
this means that the Catholic Church is
not true. It simply means it's
infiltrated.
So, it's not so much that the the
Catholic Church is not true because I
100% believe that it is the church that
Christ established on Earth.
Um it's the it's the idea of I'm sitting
in mass and I'm looking up at this man
who is supposed to be invoking,
you know, these different rites and he
could be doing something behind the
scenes like
So, that's that's what I'm I'm trying to
get around.
>> the same thing with the priesthood,
brother. In the Old Testament, you had
Levitical priests who were corrupt and
evil, immoral.
And yet because people may have not
known that, they still had to go to the
priests and give their sacrifices for
the forgiveness of sins. That's my
entire point. That you're going to have
wolves masquerading as servants, but you
don't know they're wolves.
And to no fault of your own, you're not
held accountable. We can even go with
Jesus. Judas Iscariot. He did miracles.
I can give you the receipts if you want
to see them. I'll I'll bring them up now
if you want.
He cast out demons. He raised the dead.
He gave sight to the blind. He preached
the gospel, got people converted. And
yet Jesus said, "One of you is the
devil." And he was stealing money
from the money box cuz he was entrusted
as the treasury
>> [clears throat]
>> treasurer
overlooking the financial support and it
says he was stealing money.
And yet for that entire 3-year period,
Christ did not expose him, defrock him,
or replace him.
So, you saw Judas, you didn't see a son
of Satan. Jesus did.
People thought that he was a follower of
Christ. In fact, even on the night of
his betrayal, when Jesus said, "One of
you is going to betray me." And he goes,
"The one that I give this morsel to."
And he gave it to Judas and they still
didn't recognize or realize Judas is the
betrayer.
In other words, Judas was so good at
covering up that the disciples did not
suspect him in the least,
right?
Of being
the one who'd betray Christ.
But Jesus never defrocked him.
So, the the authority invested in a
priest is not, even though they may be
in a state of mortal sin, does not alter
their
Yeah, let me show you from Judas so you
don't think yeah, Judas. Judas is the
best example of how a son of Satan
can still
do miracles
by the power and authority of Christ so
that his state does not nullify the
graces that God communicates through
those acts. Let me show it to you. Let
me get the good translation.
So, yeah, I've already struggled with
this, but because of what I see in
scripture,
and by the way, the grass is not greener
on the other side. There is not a church
that's not rocked with scandal.
All right. I 100% believe that, too. No,
I mean there's a website called Julie
Roys. All she does is expose corruptions
in the Protestant churches and the mega
churches.
So, that means if we
look at all the scandals, we're all
going to end up staying home.
Matthew 10
1 take. [clears throat]
And summoning his 12 disciples, Jesus
gave them authority over clean spirits
to cast them out and to heal every kind
of disease, every kind of sickness. Now,
he mentions the 12 starting with Peter,
but it ends with Judas, right? Right.
Look at the authority given to Judas.
These 12 Jesus sent out after
instructing them saying, "Do not go in
the way of the Gentiles.
Do not enter in any city of the
Samaritans, but rather go to the lost
sheep of the house of Israel. And as you
go, preach saying, 'The kingdom of
heaven is at hand.' Heal the sick, raise
the dead, cleanse the lepers, cast out
demons." So, Judas is going to heal the
sick,
resurrect the dead, cleanse lepers, cast
out demons.
Freely you receive, freely
give.
So, Judas' state of being a son of Satan
did not nullify the graces of those
actions that Christ sent them out to do.
Was that Was he skimming off the top at
that point already or All through all of
the ministry, Jesus says, "One of you is
a devil."
You're right here. Early on.
This is all throughout the ministry
sending them out.
And here John 6, he says,
"Jesus answered them, 'Did I myself not
choose you, the 12, and yet one of you
is a devil?'"
"Now he's speaking of Judas the son of
Simon Iscariot, for he one of the 12 was
going to betray him."
So, he's already telling them early on
in his ministry. This would be maybe a a
year, little past the year,
maybe 2 years into his ministry, and
he's telling them, "Yeah, he's a devil."
That means all throughout this time,
Jesus has not defrocked him, Jesus has
not removed him, and he's gone out doing
ministry and performing miracles.
In fact, in Matthew 19, that was Matthew
10.
In Matthew 10,
which I showed you, Judas is sent out.
Now, watch Matthew 19. Shortly before he
approaches Jerusalem to be betrayed,
he looks at the 12 and says this.
Jesus said to them, "Truly I say to you
that you who have followed me in the
regeneration, when the son of man will
sit on his glorious throne, you also
shall sit upon 12 thrones judging the 12
tribes of Israel."
In spite of his condition,
in spite of his state,
God's heart for Judas was that Judas
would be saved, not be destroyed.
That's why he says, "You follow me."
Condition.
You will sit on a 12 one of the 12
thrones.
But he stopped following him.
But at no point did Jesus
defrock him.
At no point.
Okay.
That's all it is, brother.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you so much.
That that 1% should not deter you
because that 1% would not have deterred
Old Testament
um saints or the people of God from
going to priests who may have been
corrupt, ravenous wolves, immoral
idolaters, or to the kings.
Got it.
Thank you so much. I I appreciate that.
It's
it's been a a very interesting journey
up to this point. Yeah, for all of us,
brother, and it's ups and downs and it
doesn't get easier, but it's worth it.
Sacrifice is worth it.
I appreciate it. Thank you. God bless.
>> Now, hey brother, before you go on, you
see Assembly of God, right? Julie Roys.
I just brought up to show you. November
4. Julie Roys, she exposes corruption in
Protestant Evangelical Churches. Report
outlines decades of sexual abuse in
Assemblies of God denomination.
See?
Yeah, like I I see it all the time, too.
I'm from Texas and there's all kinds of
scandals coming up on the news that that
just break my heart when cuz it's always
like youth pastors and stuff like that,
too, that are, you know, the the closest
there that just it it kills me.
Yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> I know, brother. It's a filthy, wicked
world when children are harmed, but
Jesus warned in Matthew 18. At least we
know this. We're not atheists. God is
real.
Amen.
>> God has sworn they will not go
unpunished. He has sworn. So, we may
think they got away with it. No.
That's why we know there's an afterlife.
And that's why we know Jesus Almighty
will make sure
their wickedness does not go unpunished
cuz here's the warning here. Jesus even
speaks to this issue.
At that time, Matthew 18,
we'll read verse 1 to 9. The disciples
came to Jesus said, "Who then is the
greatest in the kingdom of heaven?"
And he called a child to himself and set
him before them and said, "Truly I say
to you, unless you are converted
and become like children, you will not
ever enter the kingdom of heaven.
Whoever therefore will humble himself as
a child, he's the greatest in the
kingdom of heaven.
Whoever receives one such child in my
name receives me. But whoever causes
one of these little ones who believe in
me to stumble, it is better for him
that a heavy millstone be on his neck
and that he be
in the depth of the sea rather
bury yourself in the sea
right? So never be seen
than you harm this child
because you will have hell to pay. Now
look what he says. "Woe to the world
because of its stumbling blocks. For
it's inevitable cuz there are sinners
who are going to cause people to
stumble.
Nevertheless, woe to that man through
whom the stumbling block comes."
Now, here's the warning.
"And if your hand or your foot causes
you to stumble, cut it off and throw it
from you."
In other words, cut off anything that
will cause you to stumble and harm these
little ones
because it is better for you to enter
life crippled or lame than having two
hands or two feet to be cast into the
eternal fire. Now look at the wisdom of
our Lord.
He says, "The life we live here is not
the real life.
It's when you die, you enter life, you
see?"
Yep.
So he told you this is not the real
life. This is a shadow.
This is a shade of what real life is
like.
So better you be amputated in this
reality, which is a shadow,
and then enter
the world to come, which is the true
life in all its fullness,
than
die with both hands and feet intact and
your eyes intact, the very means by
which you you use to cause children to
stumble and harm them.
Cuz look what he goes on to say.
"And if your eye causes you to stumble,
tear it out and throw it from you. It is
better for you to enter life with one
eye than having two eyes to be cast into
the fiery hell." And then finally, verse
10. I said tonight I'll read 10. "See
that you do not despise one of these
little ones, for I say to you that their
angels in heaven continue to see the
face of my father who's in heaven. So
although we only see this world and we
see these corrupt
predators getting away with it,
Christ says,
>> [clears throat]
>> "It's not the end.
This is just the beginning. You may
think they escaped. You may think they
got away with injustice. What do you
think the next stop is? Before me,
standing before my face, and I just told
you it would be better that they had
themselves in the depth of the sea by
tying a millstone on their neck than to
harm any of these children. Cuz he who
harms them, I will harm him."
That's how much he loves children.
Yep.
So I I guess it's just my flesh that
wants the to see the justice now, here
in the now, but
um and so I I just have to learn to wait
on the Lord.
Brother, me too. My flesh wanted justice
and judgment upon
my ex-wife and the judge
for what they did in removing
me from my home
where I had to lose my children.
Believe me, I wanted to see it now in
this realm,
in this life.
But God says no, be patient.
Bless you. Bless you, sir. Thank you.
God bless.